what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to kevin
samuels on the
fit and fresh podcast before i start do
not forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell
as you guys know i'm trying to hit 20
000 subscribers so if you like my
content you want me to keep making more
hit that notification bell okay
let's do this
someone sent this to me on instagram so
again
if you guys want to submit a video
follow my instagram it's in
the description
your dating situation dealing with women
all this type of things your views on a
dating market how you get around
obviously
uh pause you're a good looking guy tall
he's taller than me which gets me angry
i'm six three i woke up but this guy's
telling me wearing a leather jacket i'm
wearing sweatpants so i'm like nah bruh
this is this is my city
go back to atlanta so can you tell us a
little bit about um you know you and
because you you you date very attractive
women
but you do it for other reasons which i
think is is
genius how you do it but can you break
it down a little bit for the guys i
think
are you talking about what we talked
about on the show the escorting thing
yeah yeah if you want to get into that i
mean yeah we can yeah yeah like because
okay well i believe in rotation day um
you know and the women i deal with they
know about each other
um and it's a business transaction for
me
uh beautiful women uh increase your
value your
perceived value amongst your colleagues
yes yeah
you know big fans if not we'd all come
on man let's be real
we would all be driving pintos if they
still made them
but there's a reason you drive a lambo
or whatever
exactly um so
i believe in quality
and i understand for a woman to spend
time with me
i'm already going to go out and do what
i do i love the company of beautiful
women
thank you i don't you know this is cool
and all
but i i like women i like a woman
sitting over there her whole vibe her
whole energy
and i have never been opposed to that
you know you're tricking and you're this
and that look man the money's gonna get
spent anyway
yeah the money's gonna get spent anyway
what's the outcome what is the outcome
i'm choosing to get
and you know we may not have time to go
in into it deep today but
i'll say one of the best things i ever
did
was learn about the transactional nature
of relationships
and when you are honest with okay as a
guy do you guys think it's more valuable
to have
like a long term what do you think's
more respectable as a man
coming in with like the hot young thing
like that you traded in
or do you think it's more respectable to
have like a long
like 20 30-year marriage let me know in
the comments women
and tell them what you want you'd be
amazed at how honest women tend to be
with you
because they don't want to waste
precious time yep so
um here's another thing
i can do these things now more readily
because one
i'm where i want i'm getting to where i
want to be in my career progression
purpose
between 18 and 30 i'll be spending
you know less than ten percent of my
time trying to pursue anything
relationally with women that's why i
like a rotation because
uh when a woman decides to flake ghosts
whatever get hot and cold i don't i
don't play all these games
next pull lever push the button
yeah and even right now you know
um when i i'm out i'm a flirt i'm a
charismatic guy but i also know what
works for me
i know professional women women
like the sorority girls and the snooty
bougie chicks that's my [ __ ]
yeah yeah and i'm their [ __ ] so we we
kind of work well together
you gotta that's like corporate america
in my opinion corporate america is a
different
world and like city life than what i'm
used to knowing what works for you what
fits for you
why and and being all right with the
fact that you know
look i do my business with me and i have
my fun with women
damn kevin you hit the record brother
720 watching right now
bam yeah they're asking in the chat how
tall is kevin uh
uh he's calling me by an inch only okay
guys so you know what i'm saying
that's the one thing that shocks most
people yeah yeah
yeah i was tight when i walked up i was
like nah he doesn't look that tall kevin
turn back right there
guys i gave up because me being number
six
one [ __ ] to these guys and then
we got our lawyer here andrew our lawyer
andrew esquire in the house right now
brian
kevin i'll say this because you uh you
mentioned something before which i think
is
very important you mentioned how you
would bring a girl with you
to social like business functions etc
um because a lot of guys you know
they'll get escort whatever it is just
to get laid
you're not doing it for that you're
doing it to convey
um authority and status can you tell us
a little bit about how that actually
helped you and project
because i remember you told the story
about this on one of the seven uh six
episodes that we had to put on patreon
but can you talk about that
yeah uh so i tell the story about
going to a holiday party and everybody
was in town for the holiday party
and at a certain age
over 25 years old going to a party
without a plus one especially for a man
that's trying to move up
it's not it's a no no it's a bad look
it's a bad look um you're either
looking as though you can't get a woman
you may
be alternative lifestyle i like that
term
or or it's just not a good look
and as a top performer um
looking to to move on up i
knew that escorts were great to bring to
a place so what i did
this was i looked around the city i
lived in which is dallas
and i asked people that i know i know
i know resources all kind of message
boards hold on
and i went and found some of the top
ones in the city
and if you go on to eros miami
or that's a popular escort site
heroes e-r-o-s e-r-o-s
anywhere they will have vips verified
and all these other kind of stuff
get familiar with this stuff guys but
the women who are vips are verified
they screen you okay yeah they want your
facebook your linkedin events or that
then they want to know
who what providers you work with who you
know
okay many guys would say what
i'm not doing all that i don't put my
name out there i don't want to get
caught up in nothing
but i'm like no no no no i'll be
transparent because
if i can get into your stuff you give me
pre-selection with other people
looking at it the other way you give me
priests oh what does he mean by that so
when i walked in with debbie of dallas
to the party oh i get it so he's saying
that the men respect him because he
brings like a beautiful woman on his arm
i got you
and there were hundreds of people and
we're mixing and mingling
and she was beautiful but she was also
cultured
she spoke three languages very astute
she
worked the room it was like i was
walking around with a light around me
yeah
all the women were looking at her all
the guys are looking at her and
i had to go to the bathroom i went up to
the
executive washroom which is normally
locked to you know
non-executives you have to have a key to
get in but it was open for the party
and coming away from the urinal was the
vp of marketing how'd i know that
because
he is on you know company literature and
things like that
i'm just the guy in sales uh and
i know him he doesn't know me but as
he's passing me he's like
debbie huh she's a great girl
[Laughter]
damn that's so odd that's so weird oh
that's so weird
that was it and i was like
okay three weeks later i get a call
saying mr
so-and-so would like you to come up to
his office when he's in town
all right he was in town from corporate
we sat down and talked we talked about
nothing small talk what do you want to
and then he asked me a few questions
what do you see yourself
with the company what do you want to go
in the next few years
i let them know what i was thinking next
thing you know i started getting more
cherry assignments
i started getting uh more favorable
treatment i start getting higher and
higher in clients handed to me i hate
uh i i hate this like i don't like the
idea
that escort helped him elevate his
career but it seems like i could
it's a smart move and you know on this
channel i'm going to tell you guys the
truth
that was a smart move and what i found
is that this guy was high value
yep and he saw something in me
he said if a guy is willing to pay
fifteen hundred dollars
at his level that's somebody i need to
keep my eye on he had been watching me
right that one move
launch my career because then i start
getting invited to
lock-ins country clubs
ski weekends see it's funny because all
the rich people that i know
do not care about this type of thing
they literally
just make their millions and live on
property
all other kinds i got fast tracked
and needless to say i ask these like
anybody who can get through her
screening
is a guy who runs because she when she
screams you she screens you
and this guy was a married guy
um but it said something about you yeah
it's
it's no different than being part of an
exclusive club yeah
you want exclusivity because exclusivity
pre-selects and there's a reason there's
a vip
a purple rope over here yeah that's what
they told us like when i was working in
like marketing they told us to sell as
you're selling
exclusivity and something that like no
one else has
and everybody looks towards the vip that
kind of stuff so
um always about the outcome and
the sex happen sure but when i
i got see worried about getting like
diseases from an escort much more than
my investment exactly
and i really wanted it it was very
important let me say this one more
question
because going out with her she got to go
out with me too she's like
when you get in this world i'm like you
know i didn't want to pay me i would do
you for free i was like i know but
that's not what you're here for
damn you're here to work
you're here you're here to work i know
you do me for free that's cool
but i expect you to work so 48 laws of
power despise the free lunch no no
there's your fee
go to work nice yeah and we still do
what we do
but when it's time to i don't have to he
ain't [ __ ] on instagram
exactly it's keep it professional bam
807
viewers go ahead right now no like the
video guys there's a lot of
there's a lot of crazy people right
right now there's a new recording with
uh
the godfather of high value right here
kevin samuels like the video guys dm's
on demand is live and we close at
midnight dm's on demand system i wanna
say something real quick and then just
go ahead
yeah guys that is not tricking you know
what that is
that is smart selection to get a desired
result
and guess what when you understand what
it means behave by you understand where
you want to go
you do certain things to get to that
point and it it's because you're doing a
calculated
move you're not doing willy-nilly oh i'm
gonna pay for nah
it made sense yeah so i yeah because i
want to break that down real quick
because
there's a lot of contention and you know
obviously the sphere would like trick
and everything like that
and as you guys know obviously on this
channel we we and
we don't advocate for that but what you
guys got to understand is that kevin had
an end in mind
so he's like i don't really care about
sleeping with this girl
that's irrelevant i need her to help me
move and shake
networking within within yes within a a
stone veil
right that's very difficult to get past
because here's the thing i want to say
real quick is when i was
listening to the story very closely the
one thing that is internationally
respected amongst all men
beautiful women is a guy that can get
girls yes a man that can get be around
attractive women you can go it's a
language that you you don't have to
necessarily got to speak whether you're
here in the united states
romania england uh south america
whatever when you walk in with an
attractive woman
it signifies a lot about about you
without you having to say a word
so when kevin's able to come in there
with a very attractive woman
attention comes guy people already know
what type of chick she is
and then he was already vetted so boom
it opened opportunities for him
and like he said i still paid her
because i didn't pay her for the sex
i paid her for to work for me but there
were there are men who were trying to
get in with her for years and she
wouldn't accept him
yeah so yeah guys we have to really
when you start playing the game at a
different level
you're you're playing uh three four six
moves ahead
i couldn't have forecasted that i was
going to run into the vp i didn't even
know he saw her
but what i did know is all the people's
eyes were going to be on me
when we walked through the door i knew
where
my money was right it's kind of like um
when i tried to tell a guy
don't buy this cheap this buy this don't
don't don't cheap out on your shoes buy
this
it's hard to explain it to somebody but
when you put your foot in that shoe
or when you put that jacket on you
spread their fragrance on and you get
that
you know yes you know and that's kind of
a good place
all this comes back down to
communication
what did i communicate when i walk
through the door that's what i was
communicating that i
am here to play i'm a player
i'm in this game this was a smart move
i hate that this is a smart move but
like
anyone can see like the actions and the
results that happen from that
i'm not here to get drunk at the party
trying to bang the the girl from the
county no no no
they're see they're they're they're
they're ivy they're they're people in
the ivory tower
they're moving makers more careers get
destroyed
or made this time of year the house i
agree with that
there's nothing that makes someone look
dumber than if they get like blackout
drunk at a company party
yo i wanna answer that as well right
cause kevin is 100 right and funny story
happens to me
so i remember i went to this master
party right and i had a date for
instagram instagram model right
yep i was on her for like maybe three
weeks yeah i couldn't get her out
this night she was free luckily for me i
had a masterpiece to go to and she
wanted to come
yep so the guy holding matching party
was a rich guy from l.a and i moved to
miami
and he was trying to get her for a
minute
for months yep so i showed up with her
right he's like wait
yeah what's going on here yeah i didn't
know you i didn't mean to come in
oh yeah i came with my date the moment
she uh she said that
he was like who are you what are you
doing kevin
i swear to you right bro after that
moment you follow me on instagram yes
he might meet on his yacht i had a
freakout party
guys don't get that if you're not in the
circles and guess what he saw the social
proof he saw
the hot [ __ ] that he wanted and it blew
it from me social proof is spoken in all
language
see they're chasing you know like the
party the yachts all that stuff
and there's a lot of people that really
just don't
care about that stuff you know what i
mean it's very important and i need guys
to understand that like
when you're doing things like that
you're doing it you're not doing it to
get laid when you're when you're
tricking to get laid
that's a problem you know what i'm
saying that's when you run into issues
because
you're you're you're basically telling
her oh you're so much worth it that like
i'm just going to pay you for sex
but like you're bringing her hey no
you're going to work and you're going to
actually make me look good
you're not here to just i don't care
about getting laid this is there's other
voters here
i was also saying something too yeah
that i learned
so because after being around her and
some of more high-end escorts
they their clients are
ambitious driven successful
professionals and they are like
their sexual mental counselor
i learned more about success
from these providers
because you'd be amazed at how many of
these women
their fee was in their actual
compensation package
you make an x million dollar you're
making x money then you get
250 000 miscellaneous
wow miscellaneous quarter mill
straight paid through by the company
because guess what
as the as a key man or the executive in
your mindset so interesting i would love
to like pick their brain about what
that's like like the escort
because that's such a different
lifestyle when you're leading an
organization of
hundreds or thousands a lot of money's
on the line and they want to keep you in
the right mindset
so if you got a provider it's no
different than
a guy who's a ceo and he takes his
executive assistant no matter what
company he goes to
they take their providers too yeah and
it's funny because
myron had a similar experience too where
we were out eating dinner right
and i just i just made my own i didn't
really know i mean i know i
watch the videos on youtube i know he
talks to girls but i didn't know like
the level of girls right
so he goes out cold purchased this chick
right
fine ass woman right walking her dog
i chased after her she's out there right
comes back with her to the table says
hey guys
these are my sorry hey hey this is my
friend um i will say your name yeah
jenny
here's my friends fresh and my partner
and i was like whoa and funny enough
he pulled her got her information we did
a video together
he did his thing but it told me the
level of that he can achieve was like yo
you know what i can work with this guy
this guy's really cool
okay that was a very interesting story
um i could definitely see how that would
be helpful
um you know the beautiful woman on their
arms
yeah i could i could see it it's not
something you know
i'd really be comfortable with but i
guess it doesn't really matter
let me know in the comments if you agree
or disagree don't forget to
subscribe and ring that notification
bell